vous avez peut-être vu près de 600000
parisien le film a dépassé les 600 mille
entrées en six semaines ont déjà vu ce
film nous allons accueillir ensemble
celui qui a réalisé le film est l'auteur
de ce conte ce que l'on peut appeler un
chef-d'oeuvre mais n'ayons pas peur des
mots messieurs milos forman
[Applaudissements]
je en fait je vous présente je crois car
vous étiez croisés mais vous ne
connaissez pas vraiment faim note
rampling milos forman
alors quand vous êtes venu vous souvenez
miloche quand votre film était présenté
au festival de paris
vous étiez venu nous parler de ce film
également bertolucci qui était venu
parler du film de pasolini qui faisait
courir coup les tendances vous vous
attendiez pas bien entendu est
récompensé hollywood va alors avoir cinq
oscars
quand vous avez vu vous aviez cinq
oscars vous croyez pas non c'est pas
possible dans la salle bien sûr le très
dramatique pour nous parce que on savait
on savait qu'on a la chance de gagner
toutes les cinq majeur mais on s'est
vraiment c'est pas jusqu'au dernier
moment mais parce qu'on savait qu'on a
la chance on était sûr qu'on ne va rater
au moins un ou des parce que c'est
toujours comme ça c'était seulement une
fois 1934 se passait alors tout le monde
est très nerveux parce que vous aviez
les concurrents il y avait une hache vie
il y avait le film de lumet est un
après-midi cas il y avait les dents de
la mer de spielberg un énorme succès
normand n'a pas ce qu'on a des nominés
dans neuf catégories
on a commencé à perdre on a d'abord
perdu 4 alors gt r j'avais avec moi mes
enfants qui pour la première fois dans
cinq ans était permis de me joindre de
tchécoslovaquie
ils ont 11 ans j'étais à côté de moi et
quand on a perdu en après l'autre j'ai
réalisé dans un coût que si moi je ne
gagnerai pas et on ne jamais
comprendront pour prison là s'essouffle
alors vous êtes vous êtes dans la
situation maintenant que dans une
situation rêvée tous les metteurs en
scène rêvent un jour d'être dans cette
situation vous pouvez faire ce que vous
voulez maintenant pratiquement aux états
unis ont pratiquement vous savez ça
mieux que moi
les producteurs américains vous propose
maintenant des millions de dollars pour
faire ce que vous voulez ce que c'est
pas un peu un peu inquiétant d'avoir
encore très jeune on étende la chose
très important ce que je peux faire
maintenant c'est au moins trois cercles
trois échecs c'est pas mal
bon je voudrais demander à charlotte
rampling car c'est une question que je
vous pose car je vous ai observés dans
la coulisse depuis que vous êtes arrivé
car comment plus que les sacs des
acteurs et actrices professionnelles
vous êtes arrivé bien en avance vous
avez l'air complètement détendu en
dehors des moments où vous avez quelque
chose à faire sur les tournages c'est la
même chose vous arrivez absolument
absolument sinon on peut pas garder une
notre nuls énergie totale si on ne prend
tout le temps tous vacants sont nerveux
tout le temps alors c'est un système qui
pour moi j'ai développé qui te permet
vraiment de garder l'énergie concentrait
pour les petits scène qu'on fait et on
coupe on fait un coup porté un coup même
sans vous tourniez portier de nuit vous
arrivez à faire le saas et de la plus
difficile parce que ça c'est une fille
je suis rentré dedans espérons gg j'ai
refait mon technique mais c'était
c'était très difficile quoique un film
fascinant
tout est alors vous avez dirigé une
comédienne qui a maintenant un bel
avenir devant elle puisqu'elle a eu
l'oscar louise fleischer on a beaucoup
parlé de nicholson parlez moi de lui
très cher qui est cette infirmière
terrible dans le film est une comédienne
qu'on connaissait peu en france comment
l'avez vous engage à la suite de quoi
qu'ils et elles comment était bon on va
commencer très peu partout parce qu'elle
est venue à orly vous taire et à peu
près 15 ans quand j'entends que l'on
était très jeune et bon à la travail en
paix dans la télévision mais elle n'a
pas même réussi à voir en nageant parce
qu'elle était trop haute
pact poitrine tous tous contre eux est
bon alors là qui tu es là se marier elle
avait des enfants à la khiter inc
venu à londres avec qui à peu près huit
ans à londres appelant à rentrer aux
états unis elle a fait un petit rôle
dans un film de robert altman qui
s'appelle la casse et je vis ce film
coquin a recommandé ce film à cause
d'une fille dans le film j'avais de fuir
mais je me louise fletcher et je la
rencontrais c'est une femme
extraordinaire extraordinaire très
intelligent très une personnalité qui
m'intrigue charlotte rampling quels sont
vos rapports vous avec les metteurs en
scène sur le plateau est ce qu est ce qu
un metteur en scène un peu autoritaire
ou un petit peu dur vous gêne qu'elle ce
qu'elle est pour vale le maître la
meilleure dire quelle est la meilleure
direction d'acteurs pour vous la
meilleure direction d'acteur c'est celle
qui la star un peu libre qu'il bon si on
a un bon rappeur je n'ai pas entre
humaine contre vote mettant en avant les
rapports que moi j'ai toujours eue
c'était que j'avais l'instinct de faire
avant que le metteur en scène me disent
de le faire parce que si on connaît
l'histoire qu'on est très proche et si
on est peut-être aussi proche avec le
metteur en scène dans ses pensées
ça met toujours arriver que il ne
dirigeait pas dans le sens dans le sens
inalco jeu j'allais peut-être encore un
peu plus loin de ce pack imaginer mais
c'était différent c'est différent ce
qu'il pensait je suppose qu'on dirige il
ne dirige pas nicholson voilà la
meilleure chance est seemo réussir elle
jouait un ping pong que c'est vraiment
la collaboration michael que c'est pas
la direction authoritative parce que
c'est pas en acteur qui est tellement en
secure toujours lead contre vous non
milos forman n'est pas venue à paris à
vous habitez maintenant les états unis
vous n'êtes pas venu à paris pour le vol
au-dessus d'un nid de coucou car c'est a
maintenant un succès assuré dans le
monde entier vous êtes venu car un de
vos films qui était le dernier film que
vous avez fait en tchécoslovaquie avant
de gagner les états unis ressort
maintenant car il était sorti en 68 68
nous avions tous d'autres préoccupations
s'appelle au feu les pompiers oui c'est
je suis un avec grand plaisir parce que
j'aime beaucoup ce film je suis très
fier de ce film je considère ce film
comme quelqu'un qui qui aurait grandi
d'une enfance malheureuse parce que
quand le film est sorti en
tchécoslovaquie
d'abord que 40 mio des pompiers ont
démissionné on proteste contre lui pour
préciser tout de suite que c'est
l'histoire d'une soirée organisée par
des pompiers dans un village de se
maquiller le bal des pompiers qui
avaient dominé par deux événements la
remise de l'âge de un pompier âgé qui
prend sa retraite et qu'ils méritent en
rien concours et une élection de reine
de beauté et pourquoi ça fait un tel
bruit c'est quoi votre doigt parce que
ils ont pensé que le fûmes ridicule le
niger et utilisent mais qui est un an de
rab comme le ton pied alors nous sommes
étaient obligés de parler avec les
pompiers expliqué que c'est pas sur le
pont pire que c'est sur la société en
général
mais après vingt-trois députés dans le
parlement
on demandait d'interdire de films parce
que c'est le film qui donne l'image
faute de la société alors nous on était
obligé de rencontrer avec les députés de
l'expliquer ce que c'est parce que la
société que c'est sur l'épaule
[Musique]